he chose Canada was a formidable
talented man who one can honestly say
was viewed with respect and affection by
all who knew him his career was scarred
by an addiction to alcohol and his death
at such a young age compounds the cruel
sense of a life that could and should
have been very different Charles was the
absolute polar opposite of your carbyl
cutout point-scoring
politician he was funny but also very
thoughtful he was tremendously kind but
very courageous too and I think above
all you know he spent over 30 years in
the House of Commons and yet throughout
that time he remained a totally decent
human being his rare ability was obvious
from the moment he was elected as the
youngest MP in Parliament representing
the seat of Ross Cromartie and sky at 23
years of age what marked him out was the
fact people felt he was a normal
likeable man as much as a politician I
say good afternoon
Charles Kennedy's minding and he
retained his charm after taking on the
party's leadership in 1999 not many
politicians could switch from exhibiting
passion and conviction at the
despatch-box
to wit and bonhomie that served him well
in interviews but also panel shows like
have I got news for you of course that
soon as the Liberal Democrat leader
doesn't go and do anything stupid
char's Kennedy and his liberal Democrat
colleagues were fiercely opposed to the
Iraq war and many voters who were
equally unhappy about the invasion
gravitated towards them the most
effective way to rid Saddam of weapons
of mass destruction must be to ensure
that there's an inspector there to watch
the weapons being destroyed that's far
more precise than any aerial bombing
campaign disaffection particularly among
former labour voters helped propel the
Lib Dems to their best result in decades
with 62 seats in Westminster
increasingly though Charles Kennedy's
colleagues were becoming exasperate
at the extent to which his drinking was
affecting the leaders and parties
performing I've been coming to terms
with and seeking to cope with a drink
problem in 2006 he admitted publicly he
had an alcohol problem he hoped to stay
on in the top job but senior Lib Dems
refused to support him and after an ugly
period of recrimination the party
elected ming campbell in his place in
subsequent years kennedy enjoyed a
status of elder statesman though it was
often clear he was still struggling with
drink he was among those Lib Dem MPs
confronted by an unprecedented SNP
avalanche at the last election and lost
though with typical grace and dignity
I've always believed in politics
particularly Highland politics you have
to put the people first even if it means
the party second his death at home in
Fort William came as a considerable
shock the warmth and unanimity of
tributes paid to him across the
political spectrum demonstrates that
Charles Kennedy's many qualities will
not be soon forgotten Joey Jones Sky
News Westminster